[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
June 30th I'm J.R Whelan for the Wall
Street Journal
banks are sending out more requests for
annual salary information from their
customers Wall Street Journal personal
finance reporter Amani movies joins us
to explain why and whether customers are
obligated to respond so Amani wouldn't
the bank already know your annual income
they could get that from the credit
reporting agencies or figure it out
based on your credit card spending or
your direct deposits right it's
interesting that you say that and you
would think that your bank
everything about
your life however how much money you
make tends to be a place where they're
typically Flying Blind so the monthly
credit reports that they get from
agencies they really only tell a bank
how good you are at paying your bills
not about how much money you're bringing
in and outside of your primary bank
account where you maybe have direct
deposit set up most credit card lenders
don't know how much people make so do
they want to know just your salary or
all of your assets like your Investments
they want to know your earnings so if
you have investment income you could
include that if you have something like
child support payments or some other
type of annuity you can include that and
you could even include your spouse's
income they just want to know how much
money you have coming in available to
pay your bills in a worst case scenario
is that the primary reason they want to
know all this yes it's a form of risk
assessment so credit card loans aren't
secured like a mortgage or a car loan so
they want to make sure that their
customers continue to have an ability to
pay so in some cases banks are making
repeated requests for salary information
as opposed to maybe once a year why the
urgency you have to look back on the
last few years especially what's
happening in the job market right we've
had the great resignation people were
switching jobs at a record Pace or
quitting moving into the gig economy and
then we started to see headlines about
layoffs right the likelihood that a bank
customer has switched jobs and had their
income situation changed over the last
few years is much higher today than it
has been and the banks have really
ramped up efforts to try to get this
information so emails and letters sent
out to customers requesting new income
information is up 500 over the last
three years all right so raising credit
limits is one thing engaging someone's
ability to pay their bills is one thing
but how badly do the banks want to know
this information is there any incentive
in this for the bank customer so it
depends on the bank some banks are being
particularly generous and saying hey
we'll even reward you with credit card
points if you tell us your most recent
income information and that can be very
very valuable especially people who are
a fan of travel cards or booking flights
on Miles as those people know very well
but the other potential upside to
keeping your income information up to
date particularly if it's gone up is
that you could qualify for maybe an
upgraded credit card or a home equity
line of credit or some other kind of
loan product so does a bank customer
have to divulge their salary when asked
what if they don't you don't have to and
it's important that you know that
um it's a completely voluntary request
there are rarely consequences for people
who decide not to update their income
information however if the economy is
looking particularly Rocky and that
lender wants to pull back on lending you
should know that you may be one of the
people that they maybe reduce a credit
line or close an account entirely if you
don't provide them with updated
information so it's better to give the
bank a clearer picture of your financial
situation yes the more that a bank knows
about you the more that they'll say that
they can personalize their offerings to
you so is there a risk here for the bank
customer if they don't Supply the
information technically yes but it's
very very rare that a credit card
company will cut off a customer either
reduce their credit line or close their
account without some kind of reason for
concern so for example if you've
typically always paid off your balance
in full every month and all of a sudden
you start making only the minimum
payment they might be a little bit
concerned and then if on top of that you
ignore the request for updated income
information you might be more likely to
get cut off is there a better time to
tell the bank about your salary
information than not most of the
analysts that I spoke to only recommend
updating that information if your income
has gone up or even stayed the same
because that might mean that you're more
likely to get your credit line increased
which typically increases your credit
score because it lowers your utilization
but even if your income has gone up by a
significant amount and you feel like a
higher credit line would maybe entice
you to overspend then maybe just leave
it blank so what if somebody fudges the
numbers about their income does the bank
have a way of verifying the data a
customer provides not really most of
these requests again they're fully
voluntary and they don't require any
sort of proof the only time you may be
required to provide proof is say in a
bankruptcy hearing because if it comes
out in a hearing or in another legal
setting that you lied about your income
that's fraud and analysts say that makes
it less likely that your lender is going
to work out a deal with you
and what happens if your income has
changed significantly in either
direction and it's different than what
the bank currently has on file so if
your income has dropped meaningfully
then what the bank has on file and you
update it you should be prepared to have
your credit line cut if your income has
increased significantly you should
prepare yourself for a lot of sales
calls so you're a more attractive
customer yes yes they're going to want
more of your business so people get
asked to divulge personal information
all the time and this is just added to
that list
we might be bumping up against kind of
data fatigue a lot of people are feeling
like they're constantly handing over
personal data and maybe being a little
bit more protective even though these
questions from Banks aren't really new
the analysts that I spoke to for the
story said that these requests now feel
intrusive and even though she has
studied these communications for years
and she knows that they're not new and
she knows exactly why lenders would be
asking for this information she's more
hesitant to hand it over now that's
personal finance reporter Amani moiz and
that's it for your money briefing this
week we had production assistants from
Jayla Everett our supervising producer
is Melanie Roy and our executive
producer is Chris zinsley I'm your host
J.R Whalen thanks for listening and have
a great weekend
[Music]
thank you